football and politics Run Deep In the
City of Liverpool the labor party has
strong historic links here and on the
municipal Playing Fields where parents
support their youth teams come rain or
shine
there is no love for prime minister Liz
truss and her brand of trickle-down
Economics cutting taxes for the wealthy
to boost growth people just seem to
can't see what the Tories are doing to
the general public it baffles me how
people can vote for them
but ask about labor leader Kia stammer
we found many people still unconvinced
by his leadership as a labor leader
these two right wing I don't know where
the Keystone is the the person to take
it there
um but we just need to change I just
feel there's been no one it's also
charismatic who could do it since Tony
Blair to be honest
15 years since Tony Blair stepped down
as labor prime minister Kia stala is
steering the labor party in a similar
direction to his predecessor firmly
towards the center ground of British
politics portraying labor not the
conservatives as the party of financial
responsibility
what we've seen in the past few days has
no precedent
the government has lost control of the
British economy
and for what
they've crashed the pound
and for what
higher interest rates higher inflation
higher borrowing
and for what
not for you not for working people
for tax cuts for the richest one percent
in our society
don't forget
don't forgive
the only way to stop this is with a
labor government
a real statement of confident intent
from labor leader kirstana here in
Liverpool balancing aspirational themes
and entrepreneurialism with the
realization that it is the workers who
generate the company profits it went
down very well here in the hall now he
needs to convince The Wider public
double-digit inflation in the UK has
driven workers in many Industries to
demand higher wages more than 500
workers are currently on strike at the
Port of Liverpool starma supports the
right of individuals to go on strike but
a labor government he promised would
work in true partnership with business
and with the unions Strikers are
dismayed
politician it is a thankless job you're
not going to please everyone but if you
support us Mr Slammer come down and show
us that'll be smashing
nonetheless starman's strategy seems to
be working one poll gives labor a
17-point lead over the conservative
party that's a level of support not seen
since 2001. the Prime Minister back then
labors Tony Blair
Paul Brennan Al Jazeera Liverpool